you
[Music]
my talk is titled engineering lessons
learned by data scientists in growing
malware score from cackle competition to
trusted antivirus solution so that's a
long title and I guess I'm gonna get
right into that type of thing but
probably what I could have titled this
talk is where we screwed up and you know
there were a lot of places where we did
screw up and hopefully we've learned a
lot of lessons that we can then tell you
so yeah this is kind of some background
about me I I got my PhD in physics
working for Ice Cube I got to go to the
South Pole that was pretty awesome but I
eventually ended up as a data scientist
here at endgame cybersecurity company
and in putting together this slide I
kind of thought that my data sources
might be getting a little less cool as
time goes by but that's I mean I
probably won't be able to beat
photomultiplier tubes at the South Pole
ever but that's alright yeah so like I
said that this talk is gonna be a little
bit kind of like a storytime a little
uncomfortable like with that because I
like to like present results or like
open source a tool or something but this
is going to be a bit more high-level and
just kind of like you know what happened
it as our team tried to develop this
product that we eventually called
malware's for and kind of the main
thread going through the whole story is
going to be how our small team of data
scientists kind of balanced the speed of
development and the maintainability of
the things that we were producing a lot
of the times we kind of went too far on
once one of the sides but that's alright
we you know we learned our lessons and
we kind of regrouped at each of those
times and and went forward so first
before I start let's I'm gonna give you
a little advertisement sorry about this
but I feel like at conferences like this
data science and security you don't
really see it so much so let me talk to
you about why I like it and it kind of
didn't really expect to like it when I
joined a security firm five five years
ago but the benefits as I see them is
the mission I kind of really believe
that you know consumers privacy needs
needs to be protected and that's you
know cyberattacks from other nations
really need to be need to stop and I
really enjoy contributing to a firm
trying to you know build towards that
mission also it's a very relevant field
you know you're always gonna see
companies making the headlines by making
mistakes in this sort of in
cybersecurity and so you're you feel
like you're always going to be working
on something that's pretty important and
also opportunity you know this kind of
you know deep learning architecture
that's very complicated and it has
produced great results in the field of
images well that really doesn't exist in
security right now I feel like there's
not as much manpower there's not as much
funding behind creating the you know the
really latest greatest coolest thing and
so there is a really an opportunity to
come up with the next cool thing in
cybersecurity just to give you a quick
overview of the type of products that
are possible by being in data science
and security here's kind of a list of
them I'm not going to go through all of
them but I'll just highlight that what
we're going to be talking about for the
next 20 minutes or so is malicious file
classification that's kind of the
problem that that I a 10-game chose to
tackle all right so enough of that add
on so three years ago of this malware
thing kind of started with this Cagle
competition here Microsoft released a
bunch of malware samples in ten
different malware families and they open
source those that data on a kegel as a
data science competition and they asked
you to you know classify each new
malware sample into one of those ten
families and so I was a data scientist
at a 10-game at the time you know we
were researching new products you know
new ways to apply data science and
security and so I thought I should
really jump into this I should know
what's going on in my field and so I
participated I I saw all the cool things
that all the other competitors were
doing and I mostly used it as kind of a
learning platform because for me Kaggle
is definitely best as a place to go to
learn all kinds of techniques you know
the the best competitors on
on that website definitely are really
great at like wringing the last few
drops out of every dataset that they
that is up there but that's not always
the best skill for you know production
izing something but but what I do like
Kaggle for is the ability to learn but
anyway I competed I got like twenty
seventh out of like five hundred people
I thought I thought I should maybe do
better since I was just surrounded by so
many cybersecurity experts at endgame
who are always willing to answer my
questions about what you know a PE file
is what a Windows executable is what the
different parts of it are but you know
through all the competitors at cattle
and all my co-workers I was able to
learn a lot and yeah the thing that kind
of grew out of it then after the
competition wrapped up was malware score
was okay what lessons can I learn from
this competition and how can I convert
it into a product and so the problem
that we wanted to solve was not just
taking a piece of malware and applying a
family label to it but it was let's
solve the whole antivirus problem
because that's what we're gonna be able
to productionize and that's what we're
gonna be able to sell so that's kind of
the direction we went to after learning
a bunch of background information from
the competition and yeah so we started
work on malware or I'll give some
background information about it first
before kind of diving into how we
developed it but it's it's a
machine-learning first antivirus
solution our our solution is lightweight
it has static features a fast prediction
time and it's deployed to customer
machines and that's kind of the element
that makes all these other things
important like we need to be a little we
need to be lightweight because when we
release a model we need to distribute it
to all of the customer workstations at a
company and we need fast prediction
times because when somebody double
clicks on an executable we need to
evaluate you all those features we need
to calculate them and we need to
evaluate the model immediately we don't
want to add too much latency to someone
using their computer because then users
are just going to get frustrated and
they're gonna you know not like your
product anymore and the one other fact
that we want because we want that kind
of speed we want those decisions to be
like on the workstation itself and we
don't want them to call out to a
customer appliance or or the cloud or
you know any of our own servers to help
make that decision we want that decision
to be made on the customer workstation
and very quickly yeah so we developed it
virustotal is a website that kind of
brings together all the different
antivirus engine decisions
it's virustotal comm you could go there
right now and upload any Windows
executable that you're running and you
know virustotal will take that file and
return to you all the answers from all
different antivirus engines about
whether they think it's malicious or
benign so it's kind of cool to have the
engine the model that I built you know
kind of deployed up there to be judged
by everybody else but it it's also a
little bit stressful it leads to
definitely our successes and failures
being called out you know on a daily or
weekly basis
it adds pressure but in it makes us
forces us to be on the top of our game
yeah so let's let me talk a little bit
about the the features that we developed
I don't want to get into the features
that are in Bowers or itself but we did
open source a data set that has that
contains a simplified version of our
mouse or features it's called ember and
it's available you know at our company
github right there and so for ember we
released you know these kind of features
from a large set of Windows executables
we couldn't release the executables
themselves because we don't have those
intellectual property rights but we
could calculate simplified features and
then release those to the to the wider
community and those features that we
decided on were first the ones in the
first column like byte histogram byte
entropy histogram and strings those can
be calculated just from the raw bytes of
the file you don't really need to
understand the file format itself to be
able to get those but then you know
there are also a lot of specialized
features like section information
general you know what's in the header of
the PE file
and all of this type of stuff requires
you to have a parser that understands
what a Windows executable file looks
like on the inside and where the data is
and yeah so yeah this is all those
features I have some examples here this
is all straight from the ember data set
that you can download but this is kind
of what the section information looks
like each Windows executable executable
file has lots of different sections with
different information in it and there's
definitely a header with lots of
information that you can grab there all
right so those are the features the
model that we decided on we went with
gradient boosted decision trees and on
endgames technical blog we have you know
a blog post that kind of runs through
all of our thinking and why we chose
gradient boosted decision trees we
wanted to balance a bunch of different
things like accuracy prediction time
cost to retrain and and the size of the
model and you know you can go onto that
blog and kind of see how we balance
those what other models we tried out and
where they what you know where they had
strengths and where they had weaknesses
and we found that gradient boosted
decision trees just had a great accuracy
with prediction time and the size of the
small prediction time and a small size
in the model that really allowed us to
deploy to customer workstations yeah so
you know I was kind of describing the
whole product there to kind of give you
some background information but now
let's go back to the beginning after
that cowgirl competition and talk about
how we you know start it off and it this
is kind of how we started off we set you
know some one of the data scientists on
our team had some previous experience in
[ __ ] and kind of just spun one up on
our local development machine and then
we kind of all individually went on and
tried and tried to develop features for
our malware score model and kind of the
[ __ ] set up of having a database and
then separate collections we had
different separate collections for each
feature that we were investigating and
that kind of allowed us all to develop
independently and then fill up the
database with features calculated from
our you know kind of small training set
at the time and that this really let us
go pretty quickly so when we wanted to
train you know actually train a model on
these features it was kind of awkward at
that time because we needed to get all
the data out of MongoDB and not only
that but the main method that we knew
about to getting all the features out of
MongoDB was this find you know searching
over the hash function
sample and so we had to loop over you
know groups of samples and then loop
over the features that we were
interested in and then you know find all
of those features for each sample and
line them all up in a you know large
matrix and if this was definitely
awkward but it definitely worked for a
while at least until our data scaled out
and until to become too large for this
to you know started taking days at a
time at that point our development was
to a point where we had to decided that
what the features were going to be and
we could calculate those and just keep
them in one collection we had kind of
frozen the features and so at that point
we could move to kind of a better
solution which is the parallel scan
where we could just grab all the
features out of just one single
collection but again you know I don't
believe MongoDB was set up for that kind
of thing that that's not the operation
that the creators really envisioned and
so also as the data as the data set grew
this solution fell over as well and so
yeah the lesson here that I think we
learned was not to rely on the proof of
concept framework for too long I think
MongoDB really worked for us when we
could start experimenting but then when
we made the decision like yeah this is a
viable product we want to go through
with this I think that was definitely
the time for us to kind of step back and
rethink what we were doing our solution
eventually when the MongoDB eventually
fell over or we just got impatient and
we didn't want to wait days in order to
get our features ready for training was
we went to Moorea dB yeah and once they
were frozen we were able to put all the
features into just one table and also by
this time we kind of were advanced in
how we were gonna label each of the
samples that we had we knew what Krait
we wanted to use for benign and
malicious and so we filled all kinds of
tables with lots of metadata about each
of our samples and at this point we were
able to say you know this is the sequel
query that defines what's benign and
whatever we get out of this you know
that's going to be the are benign side
and then here's the sequel query that
defines malicious and the cool thing
about having just one query for that is
we're able to track that over time and
see what we've changed I hinted it at it
about a slide or two ago but let me just
give you this talk recommendation I
really enjoyed this talk this is
designed for continuous experimentation
by Dan McKinley and yeah what I'm gonna
read off the slide here but Dan says to
experiment early and often on new
designs products and abandoned knows
that don't add value and I think that's
what we did really well in the early
days but you know we were kind of
experimenting and seeing if this malware
score was going to work and we did but
then my corollary is that when the
product worked and when we decided to go
forward with it that was kind of the
moment when we should step back and say
alright how should we architect this as
our dataset grows what problems are we
going to encounter and so yeah I really
think that that's what we should have
done all right so that's one lesson I'll
let's move on after that so as the data
size grew we had been training just on
one single machine that we kind of had
left over from a previous product that
we that endgame had had discontinued and
that was working well for us but again
as our data size grew we couldn't train
on that one machine anymore but we were
learning tricks like to kind of extend
the lifetime of how this how long this
server was gonna how long this server
was going to able to train train our
model through experimentation we found
that we could mem map the features from
disk and then load them into the XG
boost internal data representation you
know right from disk how we had been
going up to that point was we'd been
reading the features in in numpy in
memory and then can
turning them over to the XG boost data
representation so we'd have the features
in memory twice and that was really the
limiting factor that made it impossible
to continue training on that machine but
through this trick we were able to kind
of you know extend the lifetime of that
machine it you know double it just
because we only needed the features to
be in memory just once and yeah that's
that's kind of some pseudocode that's
kind of some simplified example of our
training code there of how we did that
so I again eventually we grew out of
that server we knew we had to go
distributed we knew we had to train this
machine this extra boost model in a
distributed way but I kind of think we
were kind of still really kind of too
focused on cost we wanted to see you
know how how cheaply we could train this
model in in AWS is where we were and so
we kind of took this memory mapping
solution and hacked ourselves onto a
desk set up and and started implementing
it that way so we have our features in
s3 we would read them over to our ec2
nodes that we'd spun out and write those
features to you know the hard drive the
elastic block storage that we had
attached to each of those ec2 nodes and
then we could memory map from that
storage into the ECC two nodes Ram and
in this way again we wouldn't like use
the ec2 nodes Ram twice we would have
the features only in in the RAM once and
that way we could run we could train on
less nodes total of course this kind of
fell over at one point you know like I
said we hacked kind of one framework
that framework was asked to do our
bidding to do you know this wasn't kind
of a an approved released method of
reading data in and at some point some
of the package dependencies they were
creeping forward they were new new
versions were being released that we
weren't freezing and at one point we
just couldn't train models anymore and
that was a you know that was a fire that
needed to be put out with lots of panic
so my lesson that I kind of took away
from this whole experience
was not to focus on small cost savings
early at one point you know it made
sense for us to continue trying to train
on just one server but we really
shouldn't have been focused on bringing
that kind of method when we went
distributed so yeah I mean we were able
to work through it
we were already able to dig through the
package dependencies and freeze
everything but once again you know
that's kind of once we've frozen all
those versions we can't really move
forward and where we are kind of at a
spot now where we're training with older
versions of this software and we do need
to decide and move forward with a new
framework all right so that that's the
second lesson let's move on here
so yeah deploying the model and making
predictions on customer workstations
requires safe robust code that is also
very fast I've talked about that I've
talked about how we've made predictions
kind of autonomously on customer
workstations without calling out to
anything else and not only that but I'd
also want to kind of stress the safety
required we have a sensor development
team that's what we call our software
that runs on customer workstations we
call it the sensor and those developers
are really great at just being very safe
you know if we ever crash or blue-screen
the box like that's gonna lose a lot of
trust in the customers eyes and so our
developers are really careful to not not
make that a possibility but that's
that's kind of tough because all those
sensor developers they're they're
experts at coding and C and C++ and
coding in Windows something that I know
I'm not an expert in but then they are
also not an expert in these machine
learning models and how to write code to
evaluate them and so we needed to meet
up and kind of meet in the middle and so
the method we did for that was I kind of
wrote some bad code you know some see
some proof of concept code that
evaluates a model and then wrote many
tests around it so here's a bunch of
features here are the predictions that
we expect by running this code and
here's the code to do it and we handed
it over and again this took me a long
time to kind of get
in the sensor sensor teams development
development boxes in their environment
and I never really totally got there but
I was able to you know go far enough
that I was able to hand it over to them
- you know this code that passed a
couple tests and then they were able to
take it from there and really make it
safe and reliable and so that it can run
on customer boxes yeah so what I kind of
want to stress here is the thing so this
lesson is actually one that we did right
and that we didn't fail at but I think
we were very good at defining a
well-defined interface between data
science and the engineering where I
could train the models our team could
train models and then handover something
in a data structure that the engineers
definitely expected and knew how to work
with so this is kind of our deployment
process now just kind of an overview a
schema of it we train the models we we
transform that model into our own
internal data structure store that you
know in kind of a binary store and then
the engineering team is able to take
care of deploying that to all kinds of
customer appliances who then distribute
that model to all kinds of customer
workstations and there's a bunch of
tests run and Jenkins that also depend
on all those artifacts that we ship to
our binary store so yeah the lesson
there is that it's very advantageous to
define a format for smooth handoffs
between engineering and data science and
you know once you get to that interface
it's really going to help you alright so
I think this is the last lesson I'm
gonna talk a little bit about how we
evaluate each model and we use a tool an
internal tool called bit inspector and
this is really just a web front-end that
kind of communicates to managers how the
training process is going it we also use
it to solicit feedback from all kinds of
domain experts we have a lot of great
reverse engineers people who are
experienced with what benign and
malicious software looks like and so we
kind of give those kind of experts all
the scores and all of our models and
tell them to find errors and and and
label samples that we might be getting
wrong and then we take all those labels
and you know use them in future training
yeah so it's built with flasks and a
bunch of visualization tools one of the
advantages of doing this was you know
the code of bit inspector kind of
connects to all kinds of data sources in
endgame and it kind of became a way to
communicate to new data scientists to
people joining the team exactly how they
could connect to those resources if
someone was asking like how do I go grab
a sample if I have the hash and I was
able to point them to code in bit
inspector that that did exactly that and
there were a lot examples of that it was
one of the unexpected benefits of
building this internal tool maybe that
points to a failure of documentation
instead of but I'll get all record up
it's a benefit this is an example of
some screenshots of this kind of web
front-end it's it's yeah it's a
front-end that only a data scientist can
love it's you got the hash of the sample
so this this page here shows you like
one sample and then it shows a bunch of
the last few models that we trained it
shows the score of that on that sample
you know back in time so this kind of
gives us a really good resource because
we can if something new comes out we can
say oh yeah we got that right this is
malicious we would have blocked it and
not only that we can say oh we would
have blocked it as of you know January
last year or something like that so that
that's kind of a cool tool that allows
us to communicate that to customers and
then I also threw on some visualizations
of some of the features that's the white
histogram up at the top and then here is
the bite entropy histogram the entropy
is on the y-axis and you can see like
packed software Becca has high entropy
that kind of shows that software kind of
shows up with blue boxes at the top so
it doesn't immediately show you kind of
what the software is but after looking
at a couple of these over time you can
start to see patterns and start to learn
about what the software is also on the
model page we have you know so yeah
there's two different interfaces you can
upload
sample and then it'll tell you all about
the sample and then you can click on
just one model that might you know the
most recent one that might have been
trained and then you can see all kinds
of metrics about how well that model is
performing and you can see receiver
operator characteristic curves and area
under those curves and then also
distributions of the scores on all of
our training set and some confusion
matrixes and not only that we don't show
that for you know only just all the data
the cool thing is we kind of split out
the data into different subgroups for
example we had trouble a while ago with
just benign installers and the model
wasn't performing very well and so what
we were able to do is tag all of those
benign installers and give them give
them that tag and then kind of break
them out and so that we could track the
distribution of scores on that one
subgroup of files and make sure that not
only did we fix the issue but we're
continuing to keep that issue fixed over
time so yeah bid inspector was awesome
for tracking the efficacy of all the
models we built to give us a lot of
confidence to release a new model every
time we trained a new one but it wasn't
showing us the data ingest it wasn't
showing us kind of the health of our
databases and everything like that so at
some point we ran into a data ingest
problem where we kind of missed data
over three weeks and you know that was a
problem
luckily the api's we used to get data
allowed us to kind of replay we were
able to go back and at least get a
fraction of the data that we were very
interested in and so the lesson I took
from this is kind of summed up by this
meme here you know a system built by
data scientists we're gonna be very
worried about our model and how well
it's performing and we kind of ignored
the thing that that model is built on
which is the data ingest and so yeah I
think I see checks on the pipeline as
well as the model are very important so
that's it that's all my lessons all four
of them are summarized here so thanks a
lot for your attention
[Applause]
-
sure so I mean there's a bunch of tests
the main one I I was had in mind when I
when I displayed that was we have a
canonical set of you know samples and we
know what the feature calculation should
be and that you know that shouldn't
change no matter what the model is
really I so so every time you know
actually that's a daily regression test
on the sensor code itself we want to
make sure that the feature calculation
never changes so that actually just runs
overnight I guess yeah so there's a
bunch of other tests that involve the
model so yet I so you know every time I
train a model that canonical set of
samples I also score them with a new
model and then upload those scores to
that artifactory and so those regression
tests then also you know match the
features to what we expect but then they
also match the scores there's a lot of
other tests too but
yes
there's a variety of data sources like
from our customers from different
partners we pay for data from different
companies yeah and our data ingest has
kind of changed over time in from just a
kind of Python script that like runs and
hits those API is from those people we
buy data from two now we kind of have a
more sophisticated set up of demons that
run in the background and that are being
monitored but yeah I didn't want to talk
too much more about the data ingest
unless you had a specific question
yes
yeah I mean there's a lot of people in
this space we have internal metrics that
make us that make us think that we're
doing really well the best yeah
I I just think we've approached the
problem we used to position our product
as like we use machine learning and
nobody else does and that was kind of a
naive place to come from all these other
companies are using machine learning but
I think they're attaching it to kind of
old legacy engineering structure and so
they find it hard to like get it in and
so I'm kind of like borrowing the the
mobile first like catchphrase from years
ago when new companies would want to
develop for mobile first like we want to
develop this antivirus solution for
machine learning first and then clean up
the details later and I think that's the
right approach now and it's an approach
we can take because we're kind of
so this works really well for malware
are you doing something similar on the
behavioral side so effectively for the
intrusion detection etc doing research
so that definitely ah but that brings up
all kinds of complications as far as
data collection you need sand boxes you
need to instrument everything and record
everything and there's definitely
challenges in when Wendy if you see
behavior coming across on a workstation
when do you evaluate a model like when
do you flag when that behavior is bad
we're looking into all that I expect we
will come up with something but it's
definitely still just research right now
[Music]